let's get started so good morning
everyone my name is Alva and today we're
going to learn about how deep learning
can be used to build systems capable of
perceiving images and making decisions
based on visual information neural
networks have really made a tremendous
impact in this area over the past 20
years and I think to really appreciate
how and why this has been the case it
helps to take a step back way back to
five hundred forty million years ago and
the Cambrian explosion where biologists
traced the evolutionary origins of
vision the reason vision seemed so easy
for us as humans is because we have had
five hundred forty million years of data
for evolution to train on compare that
to bipedal movement human language and
the difference is significant starting
in around the 1960s there was a surge in
interest in in both the neural basis of
vision and in developing methods to
systematically characterize visual
processing and this eventually led to
computer scientists wondering about how
these findings from neuroscience could
be applied to artificial intelligence
and one of the biggest breakthroughs in
our understanding of the neural basis of
vision came from to scientists as at
Harvard Hubel and Wiesel and they had a
pretty simple experimental setup where
they will where they were able to
measure visual neural activity in the
visual cortex of cats by recording
directly for the electrical signals from
neurons in this region of the brain and
they displayed a simple stimulus on a
screen and then probed the visual cortex
to see which neurons fired in response
to that stimulus there were a few key
takeaways from this experiment that I'd
like you to keep in mind as we go
through today's lecture the first was
that they found that there was an
mechanism for spatial invariance they
could record neural responses to
particular patterns and this was
constant regardless of the location
of those patterns on the screen the
second was that the neurons they
recorded from had what they called a
receptive field they certain neurons
only responded to certain regions of the
input while others responded to other
regions finally they were able to tease
out that there was a mapping a hierarchy
to neural organization in the visual
cortex there are cells that responded to
more simple images such as rods and
rectangles and then downstream layers of
neurons they use the activations from
these upstream neurons in their
computation cognitive scientists and
neuroscientists have since built off
this early work to indeed confirm that
the visual cortex is organized into
layers and this hierarchy of layers
allows for the recognition of
increasingly complex features that for
example allow us to immediately
recognize the face of a friend so now
that we've gotten a sense at a very high
level of how our brains process visual
information we can turn our attention to
what computers see how does a computer
process an image well to a computer
images are just numbers so suppose we
have a picture of Abraham Lincoln it's
made up of pixels and since this is a
grayscale image each of these pixels can
be represented by just a single number
so we can represent our image as a 2d
array of numbers one for each pixel in
the image and if we were to have a RGB
color image not grayscale we can
represent that with a 3d array where we
have two D matrices for each of our g
and b now that we have a way to
represent images two computers we can
next think about what types of computer
vision tasks we can perform and in
machine learning more broadly we can
think of tasks of regression and those
of classification in regression our
output takes a continuous value and
named classification a single class
label so let's consider the task of
image classification we want to predict
a single label for a given input image
for example
let's say we have a bunch of images of
US presidents and we want to build a
classification pipeline to tell us which
President is in an image outputting the
probability that the image is of a
particular President so in order to be
able to classify these images our
pipeline needs to be able to tell what
is unique about a picture of Lincoln
versus a picture of Washington versus a
picture of Obama and another way to
think about this problem at a high level
is in terms of the features that are
characteristic of a particular class of
images classification would then be done
by detecting the presence of these
features in a given image if the if the
features for a particular image are all
present in an image we can then predict
that class with a high probability so
for our image classification pipeline
our model needs to know first what the
features are and secondly it needs to be
able to detect those features in an
image so one way we can solve this is to
leverage our knowledge about a
particular field and use this to
manually define the features ourselves
and classification pipeline would then
try to detect these manually defined
features in images and use the results
of some detection algorithm for
classification but there is a big
problem with this approach remember that
images are just 3d arrays of brightness
values and image data has a lot of
variation occlusion variations in
illumination viewpoint variation
intraclass variation and our
classification pipeline has to be
invariant to all these variations while
still being sensitive to the variability
between different classes even though
our pipeline could use features that we
the human define where this manual
extraction would break down is in the
detection task itself and this is due to
the incredible variability that I just
mentioned the detection of these
features would actually be really
difficult in practice because your
detection algorithm would need to
withstand each
and every one of these different
variations so how can we do better we
want a way to both extract features and
detect their presence in images
automatically in a hierarchical fashion
and we can use neural network based
approaches to do exactly this to learn
visual features directly from image data
and to learn a hierarchy of these
features to construct an internal
representation of the image for example
if we wanted to be able to classify
images of faces maybe we could first
learn and detect low-level features like
edges and dark spots mid level features
eyes ears and noses and then high-level
features that actually resemble facial
structure and neural networks will allow
us to directly learn visual features in
this manner if we construct them
cleverly so in yesterday's first lecture
we learned about fully connected neural
networks where you can have multiple
hidden layers and where each neuron in a
given layer is connected to every neuron
in the subsequent layer let's say we
wanted to use a fully connected and
neural network like the one you see here
for image classification in this case
our input image would be transformed
into a vector of pixel values fed into
the network and each neuron in the
hidden layer would be connected to all
neurons in the input layer I hope you
can appreciate that all spatial spatial
information from our 2d array would be
completely lost
additionally additionally we'd have many
many parameters because this is a fully
connected network so it's not going to
be really feasible to implement such a
network in practice so how can we use
the spatial structure that's inherent in
the input to inform the architecture of
our network the key insight in how we
can do this is to connect patches of the
input represented as a 2d array to
neurons in hidden layers this is to say
that each neuron in a hidden layer only
sees a particular region of what the
input to that layer is this will not
only reduce the number of
in our network but also allow us to
leverage the fact that in an image
pixels that are near each other are
probably somehow related to define
connections across the whole input we
can apply this same principle by sliding
up the patch window across the entirety
of the input image in this case by two
units in this way we'll take into
account the spatial structure that's
present but remember our ultimate task
is to learn visual features and we can
do this by smartly weighting the
connections between a patch of our input
to the neuron it's connected to in the
next hidden layer so as to detect
particular features present in that
input and essentially what this amounts
to is applying a filter a set of weights
to extract local features and it would
be useful for us in our classification
pipeline to have many different features
to work with and we can do this by using
multiple filters multiple sets of
weights and finally we want to be able
to share the parameters of each filter
across all the connections between the
input layer and the next layer because
the features that matter in one part of
the input should matter elsewhere this
is the same concept of spatial
invariants that I alluded to earlier in
practice this amounts to a patchy
operation known as convolution let's
first think about this at a high level
suppose we have a four by four filter
which means we have 16 different weights
and we're going to apply the same filter
to four by four patches in the input and
use the result of that operation to
somehow influence the state of the
neuron in the next layer that this patch
is connected to then we're going to
shift our filter by two pixels as for
example and grab the next patch of the
input so in this way we can start
thinking about convolution at a very
high level but you're probably wondering
how does this actually work
what do we mean by features and how does
this convolution operation allow us to
extract them hopefully we can make this
concrete by walking through a couple of
examples suppose we want to classify X's
from a set of black and white images of
letters where black is equal to negative
1 and y is represented by a value of 1
for classification it would clearly not
be possible to simply compare the two
matrices to see if they're equal we want
to be able to classify an X as an X even
if it's shifted shrunk rotated deformed
transformed in some way we want our
model to compare the images of an X
piece by piece and look for these
important pieces that define an X as an
X those are the features and if our
model can find rough feature matches in
roughly the same positions in two
different images it can get a lot better
at seeing the similarity between
different examples of X's you can think
of each feature as a mini image a small
two-dimensional array of values and
we're going to use filters to pick up on
the features common to X's in the case
of an X filters that can pick up on
diagonal lines and a crossing will
probably capture all the important
characteristics of most X's so know here
that these smaller matrices are the
filters of weights that we'll use in our
convolution operation to detect the
corresponding features in an input image
so now all that's left is to define this
operation that we'll pick up on when
these features pop up in our image and
that operation is convolution
convolution preserves the spatial
relationship between pixels by learning
image features in small squares of the
input to do this we perform an
element-wise multiplication between the
filter matrix and a patch of the input
image that's of the same dimensions as
the filter this results in a 3 by 3
matrix in
example you see here all entries in this
matrix are won and that's because
there's a perfect correspondence between
our filter and the region of the input
that we're convolving it with finally we
sum all the entries of this matrix get 9
and that's the result of our convolution
operation let's consider one more
example suppose now we want to compute
the convolution of a five by five image
and a three by three filter to do this
we need to cover the entirety of the
input image by sliding the filter over
the image performing the same element
wise multiplication and addition let's
see what this looks like we'll first
start off in the upper left corner
element wise multiply this 3 by 3 patch
with the entries of the filter and then
add this results in the first entry in
our output matrix called
the feature map we'll next slide the 3
by 3 filter over by 1 to grab the next
patch and repeat the same operation
amande wise multiplication addition this
results in the second entry and we
continue in this way until we have
covered the entirety of our 5x5 image
and that's in the feature map reflects
where in the input was activated by this
filter that we applied now that we've
gone through the mechanism of the
convolution operation let's see how
different filters can be used to produce
different feature Maps so on the Left
you'll see a picture of a woman's face
and next to it the output of applying
three different convolutional filters to
that same image and you can appreciate
that by simply changing the weights of
the filters we can detect different
features from the image so I hope you
can now see how convolution allows us to
capitalize on the spatial structure
inherent to image data and use sets of
weights to extract local features and to
very easily be able to
affect different types of features by
simply using different filters these
concepts of spatial structure and local
feature extraction using convolution are
at the core of the neural networks used
for computer vision tasks which are very
appropriately named convolutional neural
networks or CN NS so first we'll take a
look at a CN n architecture that's
designed for image classification now
there are three main operations to a CNN
first convolutions which as we saw can
be used to generate feature Maps second
non-linearity which we learned in the
first lecture yesterday because image
data is highly nonlinear and finally
pooling which is a down sampling
operation in training we train our model
our CNN model on a set of images and in
training we learn the weights of the
convolutional filters that correspond to
future maps in convolutional layers and
in the case of classification we can
feed the output of these convolutional
layers into a fully connected layer to
perform classification now we'll go
through each of these operations to
break down the basic architecture of a
CNN first let's consider the convolution
operation as we saw yesterday each
neuron and hidden layer will compute a
weighted sum of its inputs apply bias
and eventually activate with a
non-linearity what's special and CNN's
is this idea of local connectivity each
neuron and hidden layer only sees a
patch of its inputs we can now define
the actual computation for a neuron and
a hidden layer its inputs are those
neurons in the patch of the input layer
that it's connected to we apply a matrix
of weights our convolutional filter 4x4
in this example do an element-wise
multiplication add the outputs and apply
bias so this defines how neurons in
convolutional
are connected but within a single
convolutional layer we can have multiple
different filters that we are learning
to be able to extract different features
and what this means that is that the
output of a convolutional layer has a
volume where the height and the width
are spatial dimensions and these spatial
dimensions are dependent on the
dimensions of the input layer the
dimensions of our filter and how we're
sliding our filter over the input the
stride the depth of a this output volume
is then given by the number of different
filters we apply in that layer we can
also think of how neurons and
convolutional layers are connected in
terms of their receptive field the
locations in the original input image
that a node is path connected to these
parameters define the spatial
arrangement of the output of a
convolutional layer the next step is to
apply a non-linearity to this output
volume as was introduced in yesterday's
lecture we do this because data is
highly nonlinear and in cnn's it's
common practice to apply non-linearity
after every convolution operation and a
common activation function that's used
is the relu which is a pixel-by-pixel
operation that will replace all negative
values following convolution with a zero
and the last key operation to a CNN is
pooling and pooling is used to reduce
dimension dimension yeah excuse me
dimensionality and to preserve spatial
invariants a common text technique which
you'll very often see is max pooling as
shown in this example and it's exactly
what it sounds like we simply take the
maximum value in a patch of the input in
this case a two-by-two patch and that
determines the output of the pooling
operation and I encourage you to kind of
meditate on other ways in which we could
perform this sort of down sampling
operation
so these are the key operations of a CNN
and we're now ready to put them together
to actually construct our network we can
layer these operations to learn a
hierarchy of features present in the
image data
a CNN built for image classification can
roughly be broken down into two parts
the first is the feature learning
pipeline where we learn features in
input images through convolution through
the introduction of non-linearity and
the pooling operation and the second
part is how we're actually performing
the classification the convolutional and
pooling layers output high-level
features of the input data and we can
feed these into fully connected layers
to perform the actual classification and
the output of the fully connected layers
in practice is a probability
distribution for an input images
membership over set of possible classes
and a common way to do this is using a
function called softmax where the output
represents this categorical probability
distribution now that we've gone through
all the components of a CN n all that's
left is to discuss how to train it again
we'll go back to a CNN for image
classification during training we learn
the weights of the convolutional filters
what features the network is detecting
and in this case we'll also learn the
weights of the fully connected layers
since the output for classification is a
probability distribution we can use
cross entropy loss for optimization with
back prop okay so I'd like to take a
closer look at CN NS for classification
and discuss what is arguably the most
famous example of a CNN the the ones
trained and tested on the image net
dataset imagenet is a massive dataset
with over 14 million images spanning
20,000 different categories for example
there are
nine different pictures of bananas in
this dataset alone even better
bananas are succinctly described as an
elongated crescent-shaped yellow fruit
with soft sweet flesh which both gives a
pretty good descriptive value of what
about banana is and speaks to its
deliciousness
so the creators of the image net dataset
also have created a set of visual
recognition challenges beyond this data
set and what's most famous is the image
net classification task where users are
challengers are simply tasked with
producing a list of the object
categories present in a given image
across 1000 different categories and the
results of the neural networks have had
on this classification tasks are pretty
remarkable 2012 was the first time a CNN
won this challenge with the famous Alex
net CNN and since then neural networks
have dominated the competition and the
error has kept decreasing surpassing
human error in 2015 with the resonant
architecture but with improved accuracy
the number of layers in these networks
has been increasing quite dramatically
so there's a trade-off here right build
your network deeper how deep can you go
so so far we've talked only about using
CNN's for image classification but in
reality this idea of using convolutional
layers to extract features can extend to
a number of different applications when
we consider to CNN for classification we
saw that we could think of it in two
parts feature learning and the
classification what is at the core of
the convolutional neural networks is is
the feature learning pipeline after that
we can really change what follows to
suit the application that we desire for
example the portion following the Khan
lucien layers may look different for
different image classification domains
we can also introduce new architectures
beyond fully connected layers for tasks
such as segmentation and image
captioning so today I'd like to go
through three different applications of
CNN's beyond image classification
semantic segmentation where the task is
to assign each pixel in an image an
object class to produce a segmentation
of that image object detection where we
are tasked with detecting instances of
semantic objects in an image and image
captioning where the task is to generate
a short description of the image that
captures its semantic content so first
let's talk about semantic segmentation
with fully convolutional net works or
fcns here the network again takes an
image input of arbitrary size but
instead it has to produce a
correspondingly sized output where each
pixel has been assigned a class label
which we can then visualize as a
segmentation as we saw before with CNN s
for image classification we first have a
series of convolutional layers that are
down sampling operations for future
extraction and this results in a
hierarchy of learned features now the
difference is that we have a series of
up sampling operations to increase the
resolution of our output from the Foley
from the convolutional layers and to
then combine this output of the up
sampling operations with those from our
down sampling path to produce a
segmentation one application of this
sort of architecture is to the real-time
segmentation of the driving scene here
the network has this encoder decoder
architecture for encoding the
architecture is very similar to what we
discussed earlier earlier convolutional
layers to learn a hierarchy of future
maps and then the decoder portion of the
network actually uses the end
from pooling operations to up sample
from these feature maps and output a
segmentation another way CNN's have been
extended and applied is for object
detection where we're trying to learn
features that characterize particular
regions of the input and then classify
those regions the original pipeline for
doing this called our CNN is pretty
straightforward
given an input image the algorithm
extracts region proposals bottom-up
computes features for each of these
proposals using convolutional layers and
then classifies each region proposal but
there's a huge downside to this so in
their in their original pipeline this
group extracted about 2000 different
region proposals which meant that they
had to run two thousand cnn's for
feature extraction so since then they're
and that takes a really really long time
so since then there have been extensions
of this basic idea one being to first
run the CNN on the input image to first
extract features and then get region
proposals from the future Maps finally
let's consider image captioning so
suppose we're given an image of a cat
riding a skateboard in classification
our task is to output a class label for
this image cat and as we've probably
hammered home by now this is done by
feeding our input image through a set of
convolutional layers extracting features
and then passing these features on to
fully connected layers to predict a
label in image captioning we want to
generate a sentence that describes the
semantic content of the same image so
let's take the same network from before
and remove the fully connected layers at
the end now we only have convolutional
layers to extract features and will
replace the fully connected layers with
a recurrent neural network the output of
the convolutional layers gives us a
fixed length encoding of the features
present in our input image
which we can use to initialize an RNN
that we can then train to predict the
words that describe this image using
using the Arnon so now that we've talked
about convolutional neural networks
their applications we can introduce some
tools that have recently been been
designed to probe and visualize the
inner workings of a CN n to get at this
question of what is the network actually
seeing so first off a few years ago
there was a paper that published an
interactive visualization tool of a
convolutional neural network trained on
a dataset of handwritten digits a very
famous data set called M nest and you
can play around with this tool to
visualize the behavior of the network
given a number that you yourself draw in
and what you're seeing here is the
feature maps for this seven that someone
has drawn in and as we can see in the
first layer the first six filters are
showing primarily edged detection and
deeper layers will start to pick up on
corners crosses curves more complex
features the exact hierarchy that that
we introduced in the beginning of this
lecture a second method which you'll you
yourself will have the chance to play
around with in the second lap is called
class activation Maps or cams cams
generate a heat map that indicates the
regions of an image - which are CNN for
classification attends to in its final
layers and the way that this is computed
is is the following we choose an output
class that we want to visualize we can
then obtain the weights from the last
fully connected layer because these
represent the importance of each of the
final feature maps in outputting that
class we can compute our heat map as
simply a weighted combination of each of
the final convolutional feature maps
using the weights from the last fully
connected layer we can apply cams to
visualize both the
activation maps for the most likely
predictions of an object class for one
image as you see on the left and also to
visualize the image regions used by the
CNN to identify in different instances
of one object class as you see on the
right so to conclude this talk I'd like
to take a brief consideration of how
deep learning for computer vision has
really made an impact over the past
several years and the advances that have
been made in deep learning for computer
vision would really not be possible
without the available availability of
large and well annotated image datasets
and this has really facilitated the
progress that's been made some datasets
include image net which we discussed and
this a data set of handwritten digits
which was used in some of the first big
CNN papers places a database from here
at MIT of scenes and landscapes and
cypher 10 which contains images from ten
different categories listed here the
impact has been broad and deep and
spanning a variety of different fields
everything from medicine to self-driving
cars to security one area in which
convolutional neural networks really
made a big impact early on was in facial
recognition software and if you think
about it nowadays this software is
pretty much ubiquitous from social media
to security systems another area that's
generated generated a lot of excitement
as of late is in autonomous vehicles and
self-driving cars so NVIDIA has a
research team working on a CNN based
system for end-to-end control of
self-driving cars their pipeline feeds a
single image from a camera on the car to
a CNN that directly outputs a single
number which is the steering is the
predicted steering wheel angle and the
man
you see in this video is actually one of
our guest lectures and on Thursday we'll
hear about how his team is is developing
this platform finally we've also seen a
significant impact in the medical field
where deep learning models have been
applied to the analysis of a whole host
of different types of medical images
just this past year a team from Stanford
developed a CNN that could achieve
dermatologists level classification of
skin lesions so you can imagine and this
is what they actually did having an app
on your phone where you take a picture
upload that picture to the app it's fed
into a CNN that gen that then generates
a prediction of whether or not that
lesion is reason for concern so to
summarize what we've covered in today's
lecture we first consider the origins of
the computer vision problem how we can
represent images as arrays of pixel
values and what convolutions are how
they work we then discuss the basic
architecture of cnn's
and finally we extended this to consider
some different applications of
convolutional neural networks and also
talked a bit about how we can visualize
their behavior so with that I'd like to
conclude I'm happy to take questions
after the lecture portion is over it's
now my pleasure to introduce our next
speaker a special guest professor Aaron
Kerrville from the University of
Montreal
professor Kerrville is one of the
creators of generative adversarial
networks and he'll be talking to us
about deep generative models and their
applications so please join me in
welcoming him
[Applause]